[Music]  this  you  gun so good  Miley Cyrus performed her new hit Malibu  for the first time at 102.7 kiis-fm  Zelenko Tango in Los Angeles on Saturday  24-year old wore her heart on her ears  yeah  Miley's rocking a gold earring that says  liam fitting since the song is about her  relationship with Hemsworth I wanna  thank you  whose  come true Hey  [Music]  during the concert Miley and younger  sister Noah also brought mom Tish out on  stage to celebrate her 50th birthday  et caught up with Noah at the show  here's what she said about Miley  probably just to like be yourself and  not let anyone try to like change you or  don't read comments that's like a big  thing don't read comments because people  can be really mean  [Music]